tiger sharks are one of the largest
predatory sharks on the planet
they feed off an extensive menu
whales Birds even other sharks
but there's one delicacy that takes more
effort than others
[Music]
Turtles
so how much jaw power does it take to
Crunch through their tough shells
here in the Bahamas Brock and the team
are about to find out
facing up to the jaws of a tiger shark
is strictly for pros
Brock has spent almost two decades
diving with these sharks
what's the best way to stay safe to take
things slow
this first dive we're going to go down
we're not going to bring the bite force
gauge we're just going to see what
tigers are here come back up and we'll
get some more backup support in terms of
safety and we'll grab the bite force
gauge what could go wrong
Syria is known as tiger Beach
and it quickly lives up to its name
tiger sharks are used to diver
interactions
[Music]
they're not shy Brock will need to stand
his ground
your Tiger's coming right on me right
now
the Sharks know where the food is kept
[Music]
it doesn't take long for other sharks to
sniff out a free meal
and nobody is waiting in line
they won't even let me get set
oh look at how big she is
[Music]
she
is
if ever a scene needed a don't try this
at whole morning
is it
Brock manages the situation by guiding
the Sharks away from the bait to help
them settle and relax
but it's not the easy trial run Brock
had hoped for
[Music]
those three tigers on the drop right now
the targets are not stop down here
the more sharks the more they compete
for Brock's attention
Tigers don't like to wait their turns a
lot of the times you'll get four coming
in at once and you don't even have
enough arms to keep them all off of you
Brock has an underwater safety team at
his side
but with this many sharks around
staying in control is still a tough job
by taking the food into a more open area
there's more time to see where the
sharks are approaching from and react
foreign
thank you
sharks can crunch through a turtle shell
what will they do to the bite force
gauge
foreign
[Music]